listen I really want to start with a
sincere congrats I really enjoyed this
movie and it's so different than the
things you've made before uh because
you've done a little some dark stuff and
this is a film for all ages and families
which was at your driving force to make
it yeah 100 100 you know I mean like you
said you know the stuff that I've done
before but I felt like I had been sort
of stuck in dystopia for a long time
doing kind of you know dark stuff and
broody stuff and quite honestly just as
like being a Critic of my own work I
realized that I didn't have nearly
enough sort of joy and levity in my
movies and I wanted to sort of see if I
can you know work those muscles out a
little bit and then this project came
along through people that I'd been
working with through the the chairman
group
um and I just thought you know it has
the things that I love which is the sort
of World building and the you know kind
of imagination it has emotion and
intimacy to it a scope to it but it had
hope and joy and levity
um and still was kind of rooted in real
great thematic Universal ideas and
so I wanted to do something completely
different and really happy that I did
one of the things that I have been told
by director friends is that the VFX
industry is kind of [ __ ] and this
movie is a lot of VFX yeah so how
exactly did you get this movie done with
the horror stories I've heard recently
but you know honestly that was a huge
huge problem on the movie there was a it
was a really it was a much slower
process in terms of visual effects we
also had a bunch of houses that signed
on contractually to take on certain
sequences and then when I got into
editing turned them over immediately to
these people they held on to them for
months and then suddenly kicked him back
and said we're not doing them we're
overloaded I mean it was kind of Bonkers
that we could even finish the movie In
Time in any reasonable amount of time
because it's so complicated
but there there were some houses that
came out of this process as real heroes
for us and honestly I'm going like and
working with them again as much as
possible and then some of these bigger
places that you know
honestly really failed Us big big ton
failed us I've been talking to some
people recently and it's amazing to me
like what's going on behind the scenes
and I don't think enough people realize
um just the problems that are going on
in the industry with VFX yeah yeah no
it's uh it's it's pretty crazy and I had
never had that that kind of experience
before
um you know you just sort of feel like
when you're working with real companies
and they're contracted to do it a
sequence that they'll actually do the
sequence and you know you have your
normal back and forth on whether or not
shots are good enough and stuff that's
normal but the fact that they hold on to
things and then just like kick it back
to you months later and then you're just
left there with you know without any
work done on something really
complicated
you know it's a it's a weird place to be
business-wise I just have to ask you uh
I gotta switch to something else just so
we spoke for Constantine for the 15th
anniversary at the Comic-Con panel Keanu
and I yeah was it that panel that
actually opened the door to the
Constantine 2 stuff how did this
actually no I mean it's really and I
think this it's a you know I can have a
larger conversation we do about it on
the phone but you know it's something
that we've been talking about since we
made Constantine because we all loved it
so we've been talking about it talking
about it talking about it but uh all the
sort of DC because vertigo is part of DC
that sort of like the control of those
properties got complicated with Warner
Brothers with DC with JJ's deal you know
all those kinds of things there's a lot
of complicating factors so it was never
like Akiva and Keanu and I happen to be
sort of convinced to do it it was really
trying to figure out how we can get some
sort of control over the Constantine
character again
and honestly I think it was a little bit
of the panel but I I believe it was
keanu's appearance on Colbert
where he was asked what character he'd
love to play again and he said John
Constantine in the crowd went nuts and
people finally saw that and went oh wait
maybe you guys can go and make the
Constantine sequel
so
yeah was I think it was sort of a a
variety of factors on that note I need
to stop
um I just really want to say a sincere
congrats on Slumberland especially with
the obstacles you know um and we'll talk
more hopefully soon okay cool awesome
thank you to see us talk soon